stacy says i'm engaged to a 43 year old
man who has two children he does not own
a home he's making payments on his 2019
truck i'm 29 and graduating with my
master's degree in may
no debt no kids and over a hundred
thousand dollars in savings he pays
almost 30 percent of his income for
child support insurance leaving roughly
70 percent
for our new marriage i'm bringing in 100
of my income to the table
and i'd like to draw some boundaries
with money since i refuse to pay
for his kids we want to have children
who are married
i'm trying to protect my assets and
ensure they go to my children and
husband if something were to happen to
me
how can i set boundaries with funds for
his children and protecting the future
family we would like to create together
stacy you guys need
pre-marriage counseling you don't need
to get married
you need to put the marriage on hold
until you get some pre-marriage
counseling
because honey if you are already
upset about his kids that come with the
package
15 years from now you're going to be an
extremely bitter and pissed off a woman
angry about his kids beyond belief
it's not going to get anything but worse
instead
if you're going to marry a man who has
children you need to be ready to love
his children
as much as you're going to love your
future children
if you're not in that place or can't get
your head in that place don't marry him
please
you're not going to be a blessing to him
to yourself
or to those children for sure you
already resent them
it's dripping off of these words
and i know you didn't mean to but you
just said it real clearly
you tried to hide it but you didn't even
try but you didn't try that hard
it's all right there so please you guys
get some pre-marriage counseling and
please do not get married
until you can solve the position of his
children
in your heart because his children have
to be taken care of the man that you
love and you want to spend your life
with
has a prime
primo responsibility
and he loves them and if you want to be
mad about them
you're going to be a trouble you're
going to be trouble for him
and this is not a good marriage you're
about to make a mistake
until you can get your heart right about
these kids
no you should not enter into something
where you have to be protected
from other people inside the marriage
that's not how marriage works honey
so no please don't get married till you
get this solved
and when you get it solved it's going to
sound like i don't need protection
because i love everyone in this mess so
much that they can have my money
that's called family and until you're
ready to make one of those
don't get married